III just and Anita say son an
announcement and this is just came to
hey it just occurred to me it just
occurred to me and I want to say this
into them the camera are you standing I
don't know why that may be so a I know I
saw he's so [ __ ] angry just now but
you were to jump the [ __ ] yeah I did
that's growth on my part right yeah
victorious alright aureus are they gonna
pretend that didn't happen
okay [ __ ] anyway last night I was at
the Comedy Store and this boy came up to
me early white got 20s white guy he goes
Tiger Billy hey I'm here for you I go
okay and he goes I love you okay he goes
okay cuz um let's be together to hang
out
good night oil is it you don't know you
know me I don't know he does I'm Ariana
Grande that's what he said
what city was Ariana Grande right and
then call me and I was there with Ali
Wong and a bunch of people and I just
kind of walked away from him and he
started following me around the comm
store oh and then he came into a number
for real - I came in from Minnesota and
I know I'm here for you
I came here for you oh man right and so
I could get the [ __ ] and I knew that
Fahim Anwar was gonna go we're gonna
have dinner afterwards and I didn't
wanna hang out in the club because he
was there so I was in my car deep into
the parking lot I'm just sitting I was
playing my in my stardew valley hires
and I hear Haley Haley he's [ __ ] at my
car now in the booking me it's raining
and he's looking at me through the
[ __ ] there Oh Mike let's hang out
what right and I go I don't know yeah
what and he goes where's Joe Rogan and I
go he's gonna be here some time this
week he goes okay and he just walks away
why yeah so now I'm telling people you
listen listen guys all right it's not
for Ariana
no it's a battery that is is that you
know I I know that on the slap King I
know I'm the your leader and I know that
I love you and you love me and we're
there's
connection that will be condemned the
bond it could never be broken but don't
be crazy to write don't kill me
you don't want to punch your [ __ ]
holes in my body I might bleed out so if
you're crazy relax for good okay but the
comedy shows not a place where you can
come in at cray-cray
is it still a word yeah the kids are
using it's hot I can't imagine crazy
people come into the comedy starring
just hanging out but it really was the
first time where I went oh my god this
guy might kill me you [ __ ] made it
man
you got a is that what it is I think so
I mean yeah I think that it's a little
bit of that cuz I know what putting out
female comics that change their name on
the lineup because they can't put their
name on the lineup because they have
stalkers women have it much worse oh I
can't only imagine oh I mean extra
kuehni she was in San Francisco and I
saw three of her stalkers there at the
show oh god she's like I don't know what
to do they're just they make cakes for
me and all this stuff and clothing pink
cakes yeah
[Music]